[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
دار شويه نسوان واولاد صغار هي اللي الله
قدرهم عليه رحنا على خرونس 13 يوم ورحنا
على القراره وقالوا اطلعوا من القراره
اجيت عند
صديقي راحوا البنتين رزان ونغم راحوا
صبايا 22 سنه و2 سنه ايش ذنبهم هول حسبي
الله ونعم الوكيل جب حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل كل الدول العربيه ليش ما تتدخل
معنا احنا يا عمي بنقطع قاعدين انا اخش
على امي الاقيها قطع ايش ذنبي انا طفل انا
طفل ايش ذنبي اخش على امي والاقيها قطع
ولاد اخويا اسيب انا سبتهم اطلع قعدت في
الغرفه بره 17 17 واحد انا اسيبهم في
الصالون نايمين واقسم بالله اطفال نايمين
احنا مالناش يا عم مالناش في حدا ليش يا
عم ستهدف المدنيين ايش نسوي احنا اخ اخو
واخوي الاثنين استشهدوا ومرا اخوي ومرا
اخوي الثانيه وامي واولاد اخوي كلهم واختك
واولادي تعرفتوا عليهم ولا في حد ضايل تحت
الانقاض قطع احنا لمينا قطع ما فيش لمينا
ما شفنا وجو ما شفنا حدا الدن لان لنسوان
والاطفال بينزلوا لهم صار والد الشهداء
كله اخوي اطفال صاروخين ينزلوا الدار
لاطفال ونسوان وقبل هيك كمان قصو كمان قبل
هيك ون ال حسبي الله ونعم الويل وقبل هيك
قب قبل اسبوعين قصفوا كمان نفس الش هذا
اني استهداف للمدنيين وه عننا جيراننا
كمان هنا جيراننا هنا 23 شهيد وناس والله
العظيم مال مالهاش في حدا يا عمي اقوللك
برفوا ياكلوا مالهم في حدا ناس مدنيين ليش
هيك وين الدول
العربيه وين كان نايمين كانوا نايمين
ه
كانوا نايمين هنا اقسم بالله بصبر فيهم
خايفين برجوا قعدات نسوان واولاد خايفين
الاولاد نايمين والنسوان خايفات برجف
قاعدين هنا كانوا مسطرين مسطرين لقيناهم
هناك في اخر الدار وفير عند جيراننا ولسه
الدنيا ليل الصبح حنلاقي قطع منهم كلهم
قطع طب ليش ليش احنا سوينا هي الصاروخ
الثاني احنا سوينا هذا كمان صاروخ صاروخين
وقب قبلكم يوم صاروخ